[Music]
Sarge we got situation someone took the
ball the ball ah how cute
toothless that is not yours
hand it over all right I'm getting too
old for this shift witty PG this is Berk
son it was the home of your grandparents
and your grandparents before then but
out there beyond the age of the water
why is the whole of the Dragons
and I believe that your destiny to one
day find this hidden world
[Music]
you do know my leg isn't a chew toy
don't you is this what you want yeah
okay
how am I supposed to get down hey buddy
wait up he's not the only one
[Music]
another Night Fury she's more like a
right I'm night hearing yeah yours is
better
probably there is an armada with enough
cages for all of our dragon vein
this is a new kind of enemy we need to
find the hidden worlds I wouldn't
destroy everything you Renaud
you're nothing without your dragon
if primo succeeds there won't be any
dragons left and it's up to us to put an
end to it so what are you gonna do about
it
suit up game you brought a baby to a
battle it couldn't find a sitter
and hit it morals ever really does know
that's the key
you're right but it's time
well what Kunis not a word
[Music]